kd would have been like day one over
there we figured out for the go over
here and shake with them me and brian
going to play together and y'all finna
be mad
that would but that would have ruined
basketball too so i can't either way it
ruined basketball
no he didn't it wasn't katie it was
braun first going to miami broad knows
he wrote basketball okay let me ask you
this do you think that was i always look
at the first i'll ruin basketball he
thought he was he thought he was making
it better i get him so you think lebron
ruined it for everything he ruined the
the the disrespe
me personally i love the nba for the
loyalty that i thought was there
he basically
knocked the fourth wall down like man
the owners ain't [ __ ] they bullshitting
we doing what we want
great business move for sure but
when you think about it outside looking
in like i got people tweeting me right
now they like literally talking about
owners and trades it's like bro yeah i'm
not supposed to be talking about none of
that right actually y'all really
supposed to be going super crazy
if you're a businessman and you're
sitting outside looking at you like damn
the fans are supposed to be worried
about the games they're supposed to be
talking [ __ ] like they used to be we
used to just sit there and talk [ __ ]
like of course
i don't care you're not gonna i was a
bullish fan you're not allowed to talk
[ __ ] about judd bushler shout out to jed
butcher also a great volleyball player
like you're not allowed to talk [ __ ]
about jason caffey none of my guys jason
kennedy or or what was the other guy's
name uh randy brown randy brown you know
you know what i'm saying
randy brown shout out to him we could go
down the random boat bill wentington but
i'm just yeah i'm not playing about the
bulls and it's like i feel like now
because everybody's teaming up and [ __ ]
like you'll hear people like no yeah man
but they suck you know what i'm saying
he needs to go over here he needs to get
traded
i'll be listening to this [ __ ] like bro
i'm like do y'all realize the players
that y'all just willing to just
if they don't win this year like y'all
he get traded there he can't win this
year and now y'all just done i'm like
bro these two these two playing styles
is gonna take at least three years to
figure each other out before y'all even
got a shot y'all big and y'all small
gonna have to play together for a little
while become like an arms race though
right it's like very much like it's
gonna happen fast it has to happen
immediately or else it's like
everybody's on the high seas yeah
everybody's tweaking it it'd be like bro
they lost three games like bro chill out
yeah 82 games somebody lose three
they start caring about what the man
wearing is he coming like it's just all
type of frantic and i feel like all the
franticness happened
when braun went to miami that's when
everything became so critical i guess i
agree with you in that aspect that
things changed as far as people oh no no
i'm not talking about the development of
the game if you watch people how they
scoring today i just mean like the way
the fans perceive the game yeah they
look at it like it don't mean much
because i always look at the first
super team from that era being when
ray allen and kg went to the celtics and
won that first year but that's not
that's not lebron james it's still not
lebron james or dwyane wade for that
matter like y'all got to do that because
that was even like kind of end of kg
peak still peak kg but kind of towards
the end
you know peak
d wade peak lebron p chris bosh i mean i
i i guess i get it but no you don't get
it nobody gets it i hear what you're i
think that it changed i think when
lebron went to the heat it definitely
changed wasn't supposed to do that the
way fans looked at
the way we really start looking at it
like it just don't mean nothing like
loyalty means nothing